it's like one of one of my favorite
stories i didn't think it was going to
be one of my favorite stories speaking
of being a columnist
uh i didn't want to cover this game ohio
state michigan
was playing the same day that harvard
and yale
uh played and so that's called here in
new england that's called
the game the game but the game yeah the
game for me
is ohio state michigan yeah so
uh my my boss don square said no no you
got to cover
the game and i tried to get out of it i
couldn't but in that game
harvard quarterback was ryan fitzpatrick
uh it was
at yale they beat them great game great
performance from fitzpatrick
so i talked with him after the game
wrote a story
uh and not only was he appreciative and
gracious
but his grandfather sent me a
handwritten
letter grandfather in arizona sent me a
handwritten letter like a week later
saying thank you for writing about
ryan so great family great guy
but right decision and i think that's
where the controversy is
everybody likes ryan fitzpatrick oh i'm
getting you i'm getting your attention
now i see you
i see him shifting in your seat no i
just appreciate how you got there
that's the you're such a everybody likes
him communicator
everybody likes him but this is the
right decision
like you got to do it it's got nothing
to do with it respectfully
great story got nothing to do with it
all it actually shows is just how old
both you and ryan fitzpatrick are
he's 37 years old he's been on nine
teams he has seen it all and done it all
yeah
when they drafted tuatanga valor with
the fifth overall pick
as he said he knew it was if not win but
not now
not when you've won the last two games
67 to 17.
not when ryan fitzpatrick is completing
73
73 of his passes over the last two games
michael i am so
happy to hear and more than that michael
i am so happy
that he instead of towing the company
line is articulating
that this does not sit well with him
because if a damn shouldn't
sit well with me yesterday and i imagine
it doesn't sit well with a lot of people
in that locker room
okay i appreciate
couple things so hey how can they make
this move
if they just won their last two games
they won their last game
over the new york jets 24 nothing it's
not fair okay
it they won their last game over the
jets mike
okay the 49ers before that the 49ers
before that very impressive
one too but but for you and ryan
fitzpatrick you especially ryan
fitzpatrick i understand it's his job so
you don't want to be messing around with
anybody's job but you know don't tell
them hey it's time to go nobody wants to
hear that
but for you to look at it and say not
now well
it doesn't it doesn't really matter what
happened the last game
if it's true if it's true and it's a big
if
because i'm the one saying yesterday ah
did they come from ownership but
with a little time of sleep on it from
ownership
i did too bubbly i believe it absolutely
because i don't know
with a little time to sleep on it i
don't think this is coming from
ownership i think this is coming from
brian flores
if you believe if you believe flores by
saying
he's improved in practice and his
accuracy
has improved and he's really got the
respect of his teammates
and there are some anonymous teammates
who probably don't want to offend their
guy ryan fitzpatrick because as i said
everybody likes ryan
but they've said anonymously he's been
very impressive
but let me tell you this day
happened i don't know what day what's
the official day of the draft whatever
it was may something april something i
don't know what it was
he was the second quarterback taken he
was taken
fifth overall by the miami dolphins you
don't draft a guy at number five
and expect him to sit for an entire
season
especially they'll start him day one
then start him day one
nobody's starting from the start of the
season no no no yes you because
everything you're saying michael holly
is about tour and that's okay but just
say
that's right you know how you said you
know how you said about everybody coming
back
you know in this pandemic to play
football just say it's about the money
just say it's about the quarterback just
say it's about you looking for
an heir apparent all this time uh since
dan marino you're looking for facing
your franchise at the quarterback
position
just say that you were moved by two of
taking that picture at the 15-yard line
in his first game since his injury at
alabama
just say that you were motivated by the
cheers in the crowd
and everybody chatting to his name at
the end of a blowout against the jets
but don't tell me this is a football
decision because it's not because if
this were about
because what you're saying then by your
rationale michael holly is that tuatunga
valor
is an upgrade right now over ryan
fitzpatrick
and a guy completing 73 of his past the
last couple of games
and the guy that's been playing the way
he has through six games this season i
find that touchdown's hard to believe
ten times
to have to perform as well if not better
than ryan fitzpatrick out the gate you
know why
because this game is supposed to be a
meritocracy and i get the politics of
the pick
i get the politics of the fifth overall
pick everybody knew this was happening
we knew he was a placeholder but he was
doing a damn good job no no
no no you're telling everybody over this
organization that this is not about
giving us the best chance to win on
sunday
this is about developing a quarterback
and if that's the case fine
just say it okay listen once again
i can understand why you would call him
the placeholder
i don't get why ryan fitzpatrick called
him that in a joking way he said
you know i'm i'm the placeholder no no
no
um yeah if you really feel like you're
the placeholder
then you shouldn't be surprised if you
really feel like you're the placeholder
you know what i'm just surprised is that
michael hold on
let me interrupt you sorry the timing
could we agree on this it's the timing
maybe maybe maybe that's what maybe
that's the disconnect between us
i'm i'm not saying this was not going to
happen eventually it wasn't supposed to
happen at some point
but just answering this question why now
but not when
patrick becomes ryan fitzpatrick again
he's playing well they're winning why
now is the problem that people like me
are having okay
um do you read the bible mike i'm just
kidding i just wanted to
read the five live the other day there's
this passage that i'd like to have
memorized
ezekiel oh okay so who's that what's the
path of the righteous man that's being
forsaken by the inequities of the
selfish and the serious
tyrannies of evil men michael yeah
explain no no no
i just wanted to give you that line but
i i do want to tell you you know since
you mentioned
how far i go back and ryan fitzpatrick
goes back and he's what 37
and i was writing about him when he was
in college so i'm a little bit older a
little bit older than ryan
patrick i'm going to tell you a story
i'm going to tell you let me tell you a
story
um and i have on my feed another
tua moreno comparison
the year mike was 1983.
uh the miami dolphins drafted a
quarterback in the first round i
remember pick number 27.
pick number 27. so dan marino the great
dan marino
there he is look at him looking good in
the pocket back up here
dan marino's history quick release
yelling at his receivers
i love it okay anyway but dan
dan marino pick number 27. did he get
the job
immediately no he didn't he was behind a
quarterback named david woodley
david woodley had had quarterbacked them
and i'm gonna use your air quotes here
he had quarterbacked them
to the super bowl the year before the
fact is he wasn't very good then
they got to the super bowl uh yeah david
woodley was excited
but he wasn't he wasn't yeah wasn't very
good
yeah he started the season he had been
subbed in
by starting around game three game four
game five
mike of the 1983 season
dan marino takes over as a starter loses
that game to buffalo
then wins nine of his next
10 and proceeded to have at the time
it was the gold standard for rookie
quarterbacks in nfl history for the
longest time
statistically as as most of dan marino's
records did
it stood as the the finest season by a
rookie quarterback he was the most
impressive rookie quarterback in history
for the next i don't know 20 30 years 20
touchdown passes
20 touchdowns six interceptions that's
what he had six and a second and then
the next year
and then the next year he went through
48 touchdowns and then the year after
that
no no not 85 60 through 44. yes my
favorite quarterback
my point to you is look they took him
at 27 and they were gonna play him
because of his
impressive practice habits and when he
went to the game he gave him a jolt
yeah obviously tuatanga vailoa hasn't
gone into any games to give them a jolt
he just had a little bit of time couple
of snaps
but if he has been impressive in
practice and they took him
fifth overall you've got to know ryan
fitzpatrick
you went to one of the finest
universities in the land harvard
you don't get in there by being a dummy
so you put two or two together
it really is for the right for you
the writing has always been on the wall
but i understand reading it and weeping
if you're ryan fitzpatrick when you're
saying wait a second
what it's not like i was struggling okay
if we're here to win football games it
is hard
difficult but i'ma get to your point in
a second but difficult
to imagine him not giving them the best
chance to win right now but okay
i will play your game because i have
already played out this scenario in my
head even before you you took us down
memory lane and remember
dan marino when people used to argue
mourinho montana i was a mourinho guy
because i didn't think he had the same
supporting cast in my attention i was so
i was always a merino guy so
you preached to the choir on that
reverend i just want to say this
although he was never better than
montana but anyway go ahead
and go yeah i'm listening if
if a tongue of our lord comes out
and lights it up that will not change my
mind about the timing
of this move it is very possible michael
holly
very possible and it's not just mourinho
that's you stand in that franchise
there are plenty of situations countless
situations throughout nfl history
where the veteran quarterback the
veteran transition guy
the veteran bridge quarterback struggles
even if he knows the situation kurt
warner okay i'll give you a more recent
one
kurt warner started the season in place
of eli manning
elijah's rookie year and i believe the
giants were something like five and four
or something like that in 2004. this is
before
kurt warner's between the rams and the
cardinals
where kurt warner concluded his hall of
fame career
with a resurgence in the desert he was
the british guy
said the giants were like five and four
or something like that something like
that is that something they take that
right now
they say hey yeah right now five
something like that right but i remember
how pissed
kurt warner was all these veteran
quarterbacks none of them want to pass
the baton
drew blood soda tony romo go down the
list
okay yeah i i feel you on that and even
you know going back to
you know our friendship 2001 it was
different set of circumstances
but bledsoe didn't think it was fair
that belichick was sticking with brady
so these two could very well
definitely i know he could come out and
he could set the world on fire
and he could do his thing and he could
be better and he could take off or
he could be just as good or a notch
below fitzpatrick
and learn on the job and they accelerate
his learning curve
for the future the future starts now i
get all of that
all i'm simply saying is that same
decision could have been made week one
and that same decision could have been
made in a week or two
to make it no because week one when you
are rolling anyone ready i don't
understand it i do week one he wasn't
ready
so i can understand where ryan
fitzpatrick would feel like you
used me and they did because you're an
employee
and so your employee as a guy
right all right hey there you go
listen no argument with that you're
absolutely right that's right
that's about you right here above your
playground playboy above your pay grade
so we like that we have you on the
roster you will get us
so far and what we're gambling on
is that we have this young dynamic
talent and he is going to take us
somewhere
that you can't like you can take us to
the playoffs
you can especially this year you can
take us to the playoffs and ask this
guy's going to take you you can get us
yeah we might be able to win the afc
east but we can't win in the playoffs
with you
because you haven't proven that yeah but
no two questions
might not be able to win a playoff game
this year but next year
he might be able to take us to the afc
championship game and the year after
that we may be going to the super bowl
like
like dan marino did once and it's just
it's just been so
i like the baby one i like the boldness
of it
it is bold i like the full move excuse
me i understand that i understand the
logic of it i do i understand the
argument for it i understand all the
the rationale it just feels like there
are
political forces beyond just the pick at
play
when it comes to getting him in now when
you watch with justin herbert
like i said yesterday with justin
herbert joe burrow are doing right now
it's like hey
this was the plan all along what they
didn't account for what they perhaps
didn't account for
because usually when people make a move
they make it during the bye week give
them extra time to prep give them extra
time with the want yeah extra first team
reps
so this is the this is you this is
circled
on their calendar what they didn't
account for is fits playing as well and
then being three and three
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports